Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is the egg man weighing in on
the plan for some sports stadiums to have
vaccinated and unvaccinated sections.
Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hey, Dave, I hear that in the opening
of large sporting arenas and stuff, I'm going
to try to be inclusive to people that are
unvaccinated and they're going to make vaccinated
people sit in one area and unvaccinated people
sitting in another area.
I feel that is a complete recipe for disaster.
And it reminds me of when I was in Italy and
I was seeing a soccer game.
It was Verona vs. Kevo Verona.
Right.
Super.
And the opposing teams and they see you by
which team that you root for.
So they see to each side and separate sides
of the arena, separated by a big sense.
People were throwing cups of urine, weapons,
anybody, anything you could think that were
on fire.
There was anything you can name was landing
over and on my head from the opposing team.
And I'm just imagining the unvaccinated and
vaccinated people just fighting with each
other inside a sporting arena when one of
their teams lost my imagining things.
Or could this really happen?
Hello, brother.
Speaker 1: Yes, of course.
Shalom to the Egemen.
Yeah, I've experienced similar things, you
know, soccer games in Argentina, sort of a
similar situation.
Yeah, I don't love it.
I would rather see the stadiums take a more
definitive approach and say we want to get
back to full capacity.
And the way to do it is we're only going to
allow vaccinated people then, because what
some stadiums are doing is if you're vaccinated,
there will be one section with full capacity.
Every seat can be full in another section,
the unvaccinated section, they will only have
every third seat occupied, one one for one
person for every three seats.
And there's a bunch of different reasons.
I don't like it.
What the Eggman is talking about is certainly
a factor.
But just just take a stand if you believe
clearly you believe vaccination is safer because
you allow people to sit together.
You don't on the unvaccinated side just say
for not only for safety, but also as a business
decision, we want to fill every seat and the
way to do it safely is with everybody being
vaccinated.
Let's see if every teams make that decision.
If any teams make that decision.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The alleged capital rioters are still being
arrested.
To this day, they're still finding more and
more of them.
A California bar owner has been busted for
making phony vaccination cards and a federal
judge has overturned the national eviction
ban.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Don't miss it.
Get instant access.
And I really do mean instant the speed of
light by signing up at
Unidentified: join Pacman dot com.